-Welcome back, guys. It is time
for "Tonight Show Hashtags."
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
This week I sent out the hashtag
#IUsedToThink.
I asked you guys to tweet
something funny or weird
that you used to think was true.
Within minutes it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#IUsedToThink tweets
from you guys.
Here we go. This first one is
from @TammyOfsanik. She said...
Yeah.
[ Applause ]
-Oh, man.
This next one is from
@caringeto. She says...
Yeah, RuPaul.
[ Applause ]
This one's from @ChadBSimmons.
He says...
Yeah.
-I did, too.
-That is true.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @costco-scoli.
They said...
Wow. Don't -- Not worth it.
This one's from @wisemo86.
He says...
"The windshield factor is...
It's going to feel like below 20
if you're a windshield."
This one is from @Luv2Hike-YY.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha-ha, ha, ha, ha, ha!
This one's from @kdbonville.
She says...
[ Laughter ]
This is your dean.
This one's from @kibtastic.
He says...
It's like -- Yeah.
Hot to Mollie.
That's a hot tamale.
This last one is from @fvsfan.
They say...
Dude, check this out.
Look at this.
[ Laughter ]
You'll never unsee that.
You will never unsee that
for the rest of your life.
There you have it. Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.